we were dealing with
prostitution drugs and extortion i was
so shocked i never had it they used to
come in and thanks to abusers daily
spanish callers pakis
black bastards more torment more torment
on top of them told me i've already got
then i'm going to kill you
yeah i'll kill you
but they can't
[Music]
at the time it was just me and my dad
that used to live in the house i had to
clean cook my dad used to go out get
drunk give me a hiding on top of this
[ __ ] i'm tame so what do you think i'm
gonna be
yeah i don't have the answer to that
we're all the same we're all
[Music]
my guests today they call him the king
of karachi his background and what he's
done is probably one of the most unique
stories
you'll hear about he was an
international drug smuggler on how he
beat airport security
and it was
his his way of getting around and
maneuvering and eventually he decided to
change his life i think it was steroids
that he was smuggling on top of other
things he'll tell us the story about it
but with that being said my guest today
chet sandu chet thank you so much for
being a guest on valuetainment
okay thank you
thank you guys thank you for having me
on
and
write my story
uh how do you want me to start this off
uh
smuggling
i saw the whole thing i mean it's uh
fascinating some of the stuff and how
you got away with it
too now you run a cbd business but i
want to go all the way back let's go all
the way back to
if you and i were friends
you know your upbringing as a kid all
the way to high school kind of walked me
through who you were prior to you
getting into uh
the the business that you got into
right okay
you asking a lot of questions here
you're gonna beat my balls here brother
well anyway let's go let's go uh
right
my lifestyle my family life was uh
a bit harsh yeah
a bit harsh i was a
sick indian boy
born in england uh
racism was like a
big thing down then you know it was like
a heavy [ __ ] [ __ ] going down
and
i had to do what we had to do uh
it was all hard work my school was all
hard work
and there was no money involved
second hand clause i used to wear
stutter i had store i still have
and
but i just had to work through all that
you know and then my dad he was strict
seek
he was a secretly strict okay so
i wasn't allowed out i wasn't allowed
out uh he kept me
in the family business you're not
allowed to do this you go to school and
you come home straight away and you work
in the shop
until
10 p.m every every night and that's
after school
yeah
this was my life okay
and then we moved up to here
washington in newcastle
northeast of england and i was put
through the same
[ __ ] again you know uh
stood behind the tail uh but the guys
that were coming into the shop
the shop we had was a bigger shop and
this is 1984
1984 and
they had never seen
a
asian face brown face in their lives
and the abuse we took was immense right
it was immense right
dearly dearly i used to like wake up in
the morning and just think i want to
kill myself right
but anyway i didn't do that because i
knew we are shopper run
uh my mother was not there she was in
huddersfield with my
sister my old man
uh
took its toll on him you know took his
talk uh
you could really handle it
but we took this abuse for years yeah
from
15 to me being about 21.
six years
six years of abuse yeah
and then after that
i said okay now i'm gonna go to work
so that's when i started a fight i
started a train
and
uh
i wasn't like
that wasn't my mindset in the beginning
you know my mindset was
to be an artist you know i paint
uh
i paint i draw
i'm an author
i'm not you know i'm not a gangster you
know
but this is what like i was
forced into in a way you know
forced into this yeah because uh i had
no other option because the family was
taking that much abuse
i had to make some moves
had to make some moves
so i went okay so i started training i
started a fight i started box
um
and then i started to take
okay
shoplifters
come in the shop here okay
before if i was younger
i know they're stolen but i know they're
like harder than me tougher than me and
there's a few of them
so
i won't say nothing you know
you know but that made me feel bad yeah
one used to walk out of my shop with my
products
and i don't say nothing
so that's what made me do it
so after that
i took them all out
i followed them i tracked them all down
and i smashed everyone up
but that took me a few years
and then after that uh
i turned to
security work
and
i was working there
and then there was a
demand for
steroids so okay i'll source this i can
solve this
and so i sourced a bit blah blah blah
demand was massive
demand was massive this is
the early the early 90s
early 90s demand was huge
so i put my brain together i want the
cheapest place to go in the world
karachi
nobody wants to work with that country
you know taliban al-qaeda active yeah
nobody wonder who wants to go there
but everything in that country is so
cheap
it's so cheap
so this is where i said this is where
i'm going i priced goods yeah
the steroid i was bringing over
valium
tablets i was bringing over
i priced them all over the country
all over all of the world
pakistan
karachi cheapest place
anywhere i went there
and
it took me a while it took me a while
yet to source
the
meantime guys
uh we went to
small time people first and
they were going listen we can't supply
the amount you want because i wanted uh
50 000 ampoules
thousand ampoules yeah on my first visit
they were costing me then
uh
thirty
thirty pence
thirty pence street value in england
three pound fifty
and
but in bulk on a thousand i sold for
140.
so
the level was massive but then i moved
on to the pills
the pills i was doing
the markup amount was huge
for a thousand tablets i was paying
nine
which pounds
probably about
five
dollars in your part
and i was getting street value here a
thousand pound
thousand pound on the street
two hundred times more than what you
were spending
yeah brother
and this is what i was doing
people don't realize this yes there's
like um
it's not all about the heroine it's not
all about the the cork yeah there's a
lot of other things involved in this
here but my mistake was this i was
bringing them back
through to england
their chief narcotics officer
the chief of police in
karachi paid off
paid off
they told me they
they knew about my trips they said you
just pay me
a hundred pounds of suitcase
and we will pass every case
through
through the airport he said i don't care
what's in it it don't matter
but i will pass that through
bam
when i used to land at the airport
vip i don't
i never stood anywhere
the chief narcotics officer used to walk
me through
bypass
every x-ray machine
every security everything boom
and all he wanted was a hundred pounds
of suitcase
but there was about
five cases yeah
five cases uh we were doing about
quarter of a million
tablets at the time
two hundred thousand tablets at a time
quarter million at a time yeah quarter
of a million but they're costing me
hardly nothing but i was selling them
for
high amounts
yeah
so it was was it was it pretty easy for
you to buy guys out uh with the at the
airport at karachi yeah easy easy easy
easy
dollar all you've got show is the money
and their work because the guys at the
airports there's really make at the time
the
top guys there's only making about
three to four hundred pound a month
so if you're taking
bribes you know
you're gonna you you know it's because
you know it's gonna work it's gonna work
so did they do they want money from you
that they want your product from you i
know one story is you gave them a lot of
money from me yeah they want money from
you who who were the guys at the airport
that wanted porn magazine from you like
they wanted you know the the guy
guys
these are the guys who you meet
initially you know when you go initially
yeah
and they go okay
open up your bags yeah
open it with bags all right around okay
open my bags here
full of gear it was a bit embarrassing
right okay
but there were some
porn mugs we we had there right okay
and
one of
the guys goes
wow
and then and and then he had to look at
it
he went i've never seen a naked white
woman in my life however
really i went
take their mags
through there yeah you're gonna pass us
he goes okay
so they passed us right
three more mugs we had right
we took six yeah there was
three guys in a trip two mugs we
bought each because we know
karachi
it's one of them areas you know it's not
easy to get your lego you know so
so
right let's go and then next desk x-ray
bomb x-rayed
poor mags again bomb
played them off again the first trip
paid off
pawn mugs
but the second time around the knew
who we were and then they started out
for money
so so a second time around we had to pay
them
and then the third time around
the chief narcotics officer
karachi airport came to me and said
listen you don't have to pay anybody
you just pay me one time one time i
bypass everything for you i'll go okay
and that's how it worked
how long did that operation last
that lasted for over a year
and what was your what kind of money
were you making per month
right brother making i was making on a
trip here
uh
60 000 pounds in a trip
and how many trips were you taking every
month right i can't even right i can't
tell you the exact number okay
right
but it happened
six weeks yesterday yeah they
they knew i was coming boom it was a
regular occurrences yeah
uh there was a lot of money rolling for
everybody here
everybody
and
trips i've done but interpol
were on my case
out of everything you saw valium
you know steroids what was the most
profitable for you
volume
volume most profitable because it was
easy with the tablets
diazipan right how we did this yeah we
packed this
in
tubs of
vitamin
b12
repack them um i lost a
load in newcastle airport
in england so i had to uh
my operation
so i thought right okay we got flights
to spain
barcelona
to karachi
karachi to alicante
alicante to england but what happened
uh interpol
following all my tracks and i got
arrested at alicante airport
and then how long what happened there
did you go due
time time yeah time yeah they
they gave me a hard time you know
took everything off me you know
uh any rings
jewelry this that the spanish police
took everything off me
turn everything off me uh
mules i had with me as well yeah okay
mules i was using and
to carry cases
they tried to get them to give evidence
against me
to get evidence against me and they did
and they did at the beginning
but the thing was this year in spain it
don't work like that yeah if you give
evidence against somebody you still get
the same sentence
you don't get no walk by no there ain't
no wall buys in spain
no welfare system no walk by no nothing
you can speak but you respect
what are you gonna get
so in spain how much time did is that
when you did six and a half years for
prostitution and other things or no no
no no no no no in spain i got
right okay uh
10 years up
10 years
that's what they said to me first
all right no i don't know i entering
tenure because what they did was this
year
diazypan contains
10 milligram of a drug okay
class a drug
i had a quarter of a million
tablets of that so they said you have
2.5 kilo of classic drug
i didn't know this
volume in england class c
you know
but in spain it's only class a class b
in spain it works like this marijuana
cannabis class b
everything else class a
so i have saw
then i had this headache yeah they're
going right you're gonna get this
and it was only until i could speak
spanish
in jail
julia could learn spanish i spoke to the
head guys there
cater i was stuck in
40 heads there a third of them at aids
oh killers
uh rum had eights
eight a third of them
eight a third of the
jail has it
because right speed works like this
sentencing yeah if you do a burglary
okay
in england i'd
turn over america but in england
burglary if you do
10 burglaries yeah you get one year two
year one year two year one year
it runs
consec
in spain
concurrent so they add them all up
so you can just rob
a few houses and you end up with
20 years on your head
20 years on your head and when you go to
jail
no welfare system you don't at no money
sent in
the
shared needles
sharing needles you know uh
and they're all just
logan is baby
almost the same space wow so you go
there you learn spanish you talk to the
big guys then what happens
right i'm talking
big guys big guys peru
venezuela
uh
sao paulo they were they were
in there for
160 key of cocaine blah blah blah
from that spain
i spoke spanish and they hooked me up
with a bent lawyer
a bent lawyer that knows
judges they went you have to pay all
right listen
you pay them
you pay this and they hook me up with a
lawyer
my first lawyer was [ __ ] he was [ __ ]
yeah
promised me this promised me that
i didn't get anything yet so then
these guys said listen you're wasting
your time with this guy yeah
do without man he was called
a man
amon uh
i forget his second name i don't even
want to mention it but anyway
he sorted it all out
judges
he knew and he said
my charges are this amount
i need 10 grand
to pay off the judge and you will get
half the amount
young
you're looking at nine if you go
guilty on this i'm gonna write okay
so if i pay ten
four and a half all right
and that's what i've got
so
uh did that influence you to get out or
you're still you maybe you learned some
of your habits you got out and you back
you got back into your life again
right because then i thought i was
invincible right
because there in spain
uh
i didn't know a language
i didn't know anything but i fought
everybody i fought everybody
even people with aids
my hands
full of cuts
from fights with
people
from aid
when i left jail i thought i did you
know
two
two tests i had
just to prove i didn't wait and then i
i was so shocked i never did
because i'm hurting them they're hurting
me them their bloods on me mine's on
them blah blah blah
okay i thought it is yeah but no but no
i'm clean uh
so then i thought i was uh
king [ __ ] kong and
i joined the firm
in
kids and we were controlling
prostitution
and enforcing areas
14 areas
enforcing enforce enforcing and that's
in spain
no england england how how
because i wasn't allowed
the uh
conditions of my sentence from spain
four and a half years i'm not allowed to
enter spain
for
10 years
10 years yes so i went okay so
i came to england
and i hooked up with a firm there
and we were dealing with
prostitution drugs and extortion you say
firm as if it's like a you know you know
major company
it's a gun yeah okay got it with the
gang over there okay and how profitable
was that how how good were you doing
with that
ball know very well yeah it was only my
personal sales and my drugs
that got me my money um
as for working for the gang nothing no
no not really
but it will but it was enjoyable at
times
kidnan people taking people who were
here
it was all
it's all uh i don't know yet at that
period in my life
i was just like hi every day
there was 21
police officers watching me alone
halogen five the operation was called it
cost them 5.5 million
to bring us
to court
uh we were
notorious
uh there was nobody in the in the north
of england who could handle us because
we did
what we wanted
i could speed drive drunk drive this
drive that and the police was told
do not stop him he's not allowed to be
stopped who told the police that
well that's the
cranky north
crime team north because they had a
big operation donors
so they just said let him do what you
want
hang himself more
and that's what happened
you were free
but i was free for about a year
for about a year and then
right how did it get me
follow me because i was high and i had a
quarter of a kilo
cocaine in my
glove compartment uh the police
tested it and it came back 84
proof
they said they have never seen cocaine
that high proof in england
because we were getting it straight from
venezuela
to the coast i can't mention who and
where yeah
but i got caught with that and uh
jail i got on that and then it all came
on top on the
prostitution but their prostitution
was all good
the girls
came to court
and they said these guys are
these guys are looking after us you know
and
without them we don't have nobody now
you know
people are free to just come and rape
them tax them do what they want
what we did
i'll tell you now yeah we just charged
them 60 pounds a day
60 pound a day we paid for the rent of
the accommodation
the apartment
full security all the heating everything
two girls in each flat if any girl
any drama any problem
there was a team of us the foreigners
and we're there straight away and we
drag them out and we do match them
and it never happens again
should they spell real power girls you
know you can't rape our girls you can't
harm them yeah
wow so uh so eventually when did you
decide to change your life at what point
did you say i'm not going to live this
life anymore right that was when my
second sentence happened okay uh
they caught up with me and all this
[ __ ] um
in jail
six and a half years i was looking at
them yeah okay um that's what i got
and uh
after
i'll
tell you the truth
two months of that i thought right
that's me done
so i did every course in jail
every course
possible
try to be a good boy
try to be
sometimes you you can't yeah yeah you
know you can't inside
uh
but i was the only
cat d
prisoner in my jail where you can leave
that's your end of your sentence and you
can like
stay out for two to three hours blah
blah blah
to mingle you back in society i was the
only one
not allowed
not
not all out because i said i was a
danger
you were danger
so let's go
chet
i'm all right
when is the last time you got arrested
or you got in trouble
okay it was over
it was on an event
my cousin
my cousin i got arrested community
service i've gone now uh
because you owed me a hundred grand
i'm gonna mention their names yeah but i
pulled in a million pound for them in
debt i pulled it up over a million
pounds
going all over the country
staying in hotels paying my cost
i pulled in a million pounds
and i gave him
and
he didn't pay me because
i was pissed one night and i told him i
[ __ ] his wife
right
i never [ __ ] his wife right
you know you did it
bro this happens yes this is why i
didn't get paid my hundred degrees this
is why that's why i get paid yeah this
is why i went around with [ __ ] shop
and i went listen where's my [ __ ]
dollar baby yeah and he's going uh
his wife was there
she abused me i said listen i'm here to
talk to you i don't want to talk to your
husband yeah i need to talk the money
anyway
she called the feds got me arrested
and that was that
how long ago was that
two years two years ago so let me let me
ask you chad uh
uh
indians aren't typically known as being
gangsters tough guy i mean of course
dawood ibrahim i've heard the name
before there's a
few names but the indian community has
been
for the most part very peaceful
not heard of no
when all that type of people know
they're hard workers
the work you know they're hard working
this is why
uh indian people don't have a lot
they don't have no respect for me
i don't get no calls from any from any
indian people
uh not from india not from anybody
because they see me as a bit of a
down you know um
shame on them because they're worse than
me you know i've got stories on indian
people
disgusting
the superstars bollywood stars yeah what
they do i i know the stories i have on
them are immense
immense pedophilia
you ain't gonna look in here baby
they take people out take them take them
on the boat
in the sea boom
fishes
end the story
it's a [ __ ] ongoing thing there
because there's that many children that
get abducted in india and raped
and [ __ ] around by all these
superstars
i know it all
when i can bring this
to light i will yeah [ __ ] them [ __ ]
dear india can stop my [ __ ] dick
what are you doing
yeah i didn't know that [ __ ] how do you
know that because i know i have proof of
the
indian stars there i've seen life there
i've been there
11 times
i know people there i know
stars that i know people who have
started films
bollywood film stars i know what they do
i know what they do
i know what they do man
disgusting
they all do everywhere you know
this is like uh it's not only like here
or there it happens every country you
know
happens in every country
you name any country it happens
because you are people with
stupid dollar
and that's what they want
it's a shame but
i will name
i will know
you're you have an animosity towards
them why is that
because i don't like um
because i seem to think yeah
a sikh community yeah
punjab india this and that they make out
their bollywood they're
billionaires billionaires billionaires
yet they see kids on the street and they
don't give them a penny you know
they could do a lot
to help but they don't do nothing india
is all about like
we are there you're there there's nobody
in the middle there's nobody in the
middle in india
you either got it or you haven't got it
and they're really bad i go there i help
orphanages
let me tell you a story about an
orphanage i helped here okay um i
haven't had the chance
to go there for the last three to four
years
what happens is this yet if you get if
you get out of a girl if you have a girl
yeah
she's gonna be a hindrance
she's a hindrance because you have to
marry her off
dowry
it's bad it's hard work it's hard work
so what they do there's like a
atm machine
you drop off the baby you ring this bell
and
the woman i know
comes tricks the baby
and she will care for it and i pay for
these people yeah okay i uh uh
i get money
collect money
donations and she says
sometimes the mothers come back and say
okay i made a mistake you know i
shouldn't have left my baby here but she
goes no
you can't have the baby back
go away
go away but the lion's all girls it's
all girls orphanage
what do they do with the girls
they try to take care we try to uh
get them
schooling money
money for clothing
take care of them
make sure no pedophiles go there
it's not easy
it's not easy in india india is a
horrible place
india is a horrible place
it's a horrible place people
go on about [ __ ] afghanistan iran
iraq
pakistan india is worse
india is worse india is good
afghanistan
is worse karachi have been 11 times
it's better than what i've seen in india
so these celebrities that you talk about
you're saying they're doing worse than
what you did
you
witnessed it or somebody told you of
what happened
right no personal
witness but i do know
people who have worked in that industry
and they have told me themselves
because i'm gonna get invited there
they're gonna would you know you know i
ain't i ain't gonna get an invite there
they hate me in that industry indians
hate me
they hate me because you know i will
speak i will speak my mind
i'm not like there's the rest of them
keep their mouth shut you know
i ain't like you know i like
i will say it i will say it and and
these are famous celebrities like the
the celebrities top level top level
brother
top level all of them
um
same as america you know what like uh
people have been named here
tom hanks blah blah blah so so
all these it's the same in india it's
the same lock it's the same file
they're all the same
but in india
it's a war it's like tight you cannot
speak in india
you cannot speak because that circle's
tight
is there is there a lot of mobsters and
gangsters and and
there's no mobsies and gangsters yeah
police
there ain't no
mafia or mobsters in india
the police
if you want somebody killed
personal story august i wanted
somebody done yeah okay
i had to go to the police to get killed
and they do it
you
you pay them
it's all safe and sound
chet question for you
oh
how old are you i'm trying to do the
math 1984 for 53. 53 years old what what
month are you born what month
what
august 1968. say that again
31st of august 1968. well happy birthday
you had a birthday last week happy
birthday yeah yeah thanks brother so so
a question for you
i'm watching you i'm i'm listening to
you i see your energy
um
but at the same time you didn't start
fighting till you were 21. yeah up until
21 you were a regular kid like the rest
of us
your dad worked you
very hard you come back home from school
you worked at 10 o'clock at night your
dad was a strict seek yeah it was
went with your dad and you work your mom
to carry your sister
when what what one or two events
caused this animosity in you to want to
take a different direction in life
if you are okay
okay okay yes
good question
we were getting that much abuse
of the white guys yet
there was like three or four of them
right okay
they used to come in and they used to
abuse us daily
spitters call us pakis
black bastards [ __ ] [ __ ] smash the
windows of our car smash the windows of
our shop uh violence daily basis tried
to burn tried to burn my house down
family's house down yeah so then i
thought right okay then
then i couldn't have a fight but i was
18 years old and i had a van
i used to drive the van hoping i would
see them on the road and i would take
them [ __ ] clean out i would run and
clean over baby i would take you clean
on the road
this was the mood i was in so now so now
did you get it
the hatred i had i want to kill them
and now i can't find them
i can't find them because one's in the
mental
hospital jail the other one and the
other one [ __ ] off to answer damn
they're terrified of me because i'm
gonna [ __ ] hang them upside down when
i see them
but they can't but
one of it
where are they
18 years old
i was 18 yeah
were you were you at that time doing any
drugs or not 18. zero baby i was just
stuck in a shop the first time i kissed
a girl
21 years old
i was i wasn't allowed out of the house
my dad was that strict and the first
girl i kissed that married
get out of here
telling the truth brother
wow 21 years old
my life was hard work yeah listen it was
hard work yeah childhood hard work as
well stutter i had
oh you know i
wasn't intelligent uh just hard hard
hard and then i just thought
when these when these lot were coming in
more torment
more torment on
on top of them told me i've already got
then i'm gonna kill you
yeah i'll kill you
so they're they're so so if i was
friends with you at 10 years old you're
my cousin 12 years old
i wouldn't have witnessed the angry
sight in you no
no
so what was it the fact that they spit
on you or disrespected you was it the
fact that they were disrespectful
they did
disrespected my mum
she could speak english yeah uh
stutter i had
people used to come in the tail
going oh
who's that
i've never seen that before and then
somebody in the queue of the shop would
say
oh it's a packy
and they are
and then
and then the whole queue in the tail of
the shop would laugh
so i would be a laughingstock
laughing stock
i ain't no laughing stuff now baby
cause i took them all out i carried them
all out
i've took them all away
and the ones i want are [ __ ] run off
that's why it's tough it's not being
easy it's been bonus here's my [ __ ]
no i get that i i understand like
you know
where where the rage was born
yeah there there there
when i was 18
15 16 17 18 19
that was my years
they were my years of
just taking [ __ ] take [ __ ] take [ __ ] was
it gradual was it was it overnight or
was it gradual development
every day brother every day i didn't
want to wake up in the morning
i had to work in a shop from 8 am
till 8 on a night
seven days a week i had no life i had
nothing
uh
my old man even
right
he could handle it right okay
he was on the you know he's never
drinking that right okay
um at the time it was just me and my dad
that used to live in the house
i i had to clean
cook
wash
make the food
my dad used to go out get drunk come
back
give me a hiding as well yeah
give me a hiding on top of this [ __ ] i'm
tame
so what do you think i'm gonna be
i don't know
is your is your mom and dad still around
yeah
any siblings any siblings
yes brother
not your sister i know your sisters with
your mom any other brothers or no
brother hello
was he there with you when you guys were
running the store and there's nobody
nobody right my brother
is gay right
he's gay he [ __ ] off
being a sick boy
being gay
and then back then in the 80s
unheard of
uh the torment
i got even of that alone
so he went to manchester
uh
university
uh because he knew he had to go there
yeah
because uh it was obvious he was gay
my family couldn't really handle it
and
but i took all that [ __ ] as well you
know my dad to allah or me saying
my other son's gay so when he had a
[ __ ] drink
i get it
did you ever get into a fight with your
dad like did you ever react or no yes i
how old were you when that happened
19. are you you still talk to your mom
and your dad
yeah sure
how is the relationship now
it's okay
but my dad knows he was a [ __ ]
you know
but my mom excellent you know my mom got
me up
uh my old man
my old man you know you know what it is
you don't mind your old man you know
you don't mind your old man i don't know
what if he did to me whatever but i
ain't happy about it
you know
i don't do that my son uh
but he did that to me but i think he had
a lot in his head as well yeah
and through all the [ __ ] that was going
down
i think he took it all out of me
and that's what made me
that's what made me who i am now
how do you manage your rage and anger
right now
uh
well not easily sorry
as soon as i can just go up and down
instantly instantly
i can like be happy and then i can just
go
mental easily
you know i think about when i
interviewed sammy grabano or i interview
frank colada or i interview
some of these guys i always ask the
question was there ever a point where
you could have gone straight or you
wouldn't have the rage that you have you
know was there ever a moment
but
you can't describe what it is for a boy
or a kid to grow up in an environment
like that the effects of it you know
but no yeah
no
how can you go straight
how can you you know how how how
i would love somebody explain to me
i want
you know me i was an artist yeah
a school that was nice uh
i feel that maths english all that
[ __ ] but art i was good at okay
i to paint and i told my dad
i wanted to
okay i want to go to art school
and he says [ __ ] that he went are you
kidding me
so he stood me behind the till of a shop
he went [ __ ] out he went that's not
[ __ ] that don't count
it's not being a doctor or a dentist or
an accountant
you don't get it you don't get it
was your dad a tough guy like you too
like a big guy or not no [ __ ] [ __ ]
watch out whenever [ __ ] [ __ ] i
[ __ ] seen
posse you know what it's me that dealt
with everything
he used to run he used to run from the
cameras
run
i'm bigging anybody up here yeah i'm
telling people how it [ __ ] is it's my
mom who back me up is my mom when i said
to my mother yeah when i got arrested
when i had this when i had that
anger say
what needs to get
buried or
dug up
but my mom did it my mom did it my mom
buried and dug up my dad didn't
my dad knew of it one time
and he threw my [ __ ] in the [ __ ]
river
um
if the situations were flipped
yeah
how do you prevent any of this stuff
well
you know like you know listen the last
thing i want to do is i don't want you
to go back and think about what if you
did this what if you i'm not i'm not
doing that all i'm doing is i grew up in
iran i saw a lot of [ __ ] when i lived in
around 10 years i lived at a refugee
camp in germany two years you know i'm
in germany i'm from iran so everybody
would call you a bunch of stuff you know
hey you're there say your dad you're
terrorists all these things that they
would call you yeah coming to the state
but that produces a lot of rage as a kid
yeah you know when somebody calls you
something you're not over and over and
over again
there's got to be some sort of a rage
uh is it more you think on the
individual is it more the circumstances
is it more
how you handle it what would you say
i think it's like sort of
people have this religion now it like
it's in the heads now you know
racism
racism in the 70s well obviously
1780s
rife right
mad
90s calm down
two thousands come down but now
i think it's a level
where it's
the worst i've ever seen
racism now it's a level it's a worse out
it's you know it's really bad but now
people can't show it
people can't show it back in the day it
was okay to walk into my shop
call me a [ __ ]
spit on me yeah do that i could call the
police and the police say
that is not an offense you know that is
not a legal offence so okay
fair enough so
spawn getting abused getting called a
patty black [ __ ] blah blah blah whatever
it's not an offense
it is an offense now
it's an offense now
but back then it wasn't you know
and this is what angers me
why
why was it not an offense back then
yeah i don't have the answer to that you
know yeah exactly
because of the british government
the british government
the braves come out of bastards anyway
they're bastards they are the worst
people in the world i think
i hear them
the queen her family
peter files all of them anyway
uh
they're all pedophilia linked
the lord
chet who do you trust
my mum
she's the one that dug up
buried
nobody else has done that for me
is that why you're trying to clean up
your life
no my life is clean you know uh
my life is clean you know i want it
clean
you know i'm sick of that life i hate it
you know it's a horrible life
it's not pain it's just pain
there's never
a good day in that life
if you wake up in the morning
you know what you gotta do
it's not a nice life
uh
people seem to think
they watch films it's like this is i
know it's not like that at all man it's
it's
terrible man it's terrible it's terrible
terrible
but sometimes
you do it
and you gotta do it and then you do it
how do you make your money right now
through uh
alpha
my company
cbd oil um
a cure right it prevents you from
getting
cancer cells
and our bodies are built with a
cannabaloid
system built in we don't have a opiate
or an iburophene
yeah
so if you take
tablets it's only like um
temporary
but our bodies have cannibaloid systems
so when you take this it will cure
everything every ailment you have in
your body
every ailment it will cure you
mike tyson
he knows all about this
he does
he does exactly the same thing as me
exactly the same thing as me
well chet you know it's uh uh when i
hear stories like this
uh all i think about is where there
could have been a turning point
because you know uh uh
that rage is a real late rage you know
there's
it's not a fake rage you know when
you're talking you're not acting you're
talking
uh and then at the same time
if somebody's already gone through the
face that you've gone through what do
you do to calm the nerves down for it to
not happen again
because
it looks like if you were to see any of
those guys that would come to your
restaurant come to your uh store and
they were spitting on you and calling
you pacquiao and all this other stuff i
think if you were to see them again
today i think you would still want to
destroy them today
oh well i will take them clean away
that's why when they see me they'll run
they run
i see people now in my area they see my
face
and i see them
turn their backs and run
because they used to abuse me and my mom
and my dad
back in the day
and now
they realize oh
should have done that should have done
that
let them run
but i won't do nothing to them yeah let
them [ __ ] run
yeah [ __ ] man their [ __ ] they picked
on the child i was
15 years old there was 30 odds old men
you know drunk
and
just abusing me just taking a piss out
of me you know
uh
it was hard work man
it wasn't fair it was never fair it's
never fair
so if this is not fair now
who cares who cares
chad you're kids how old are your kids
right
they go from 32 to 23. i've got four
and and how are they doing
i'm driving i'll speak about yeah if you
don't mind uh
but my youngest one i will speak about
he went to uh
private school and he's the only one i
see okay
the other three about my ex-wife she
joined the police force
joined the police force and tried to
make my life
try to make my life a misery
uh she turned all the kids against me so
i will talk about my younger son my
youngest son
went to private school
for his a plus the degree in
age master's degree
ancient history
so now he's getting a job
in
parliament
parliament england
so my son's in parliament
you know it's quite weird yeah
that's great that's great good good yeah
how do you
do you do you find yourself having a lot
of people in your life trying to fix you
like they you
do you find people trying to be like hey
you should do this hey you should do
this hey you should no
no okay no no how do you find your piece
how do you find your piece what are you
what source brings you peace
i know you said mom but
how do you because
obviously if i'm looking at you i feel
the rage your eyes have fire in them
okay
you're the kind of guy that you
shouldn't drink coffee
steroids is probably not good for you
you definitely ought to stay from
cocaine you definitely ought to say any
any kind of hires you know like you
energy drinks is not a good for you how
do you go to peace place yourself
i don't get peace brother i got it i
don't get peace for that uh
peace
company if i have if they're good if you
take my mind off it
if you don't take my mind off it and
then no it's like that cause i just go
drowning around
have you ever have you ever had a steady
therapist or somebody that you sat down
with on a weekly basis or not yes yes i
have yeah
but all they do is
listen
to what you're saying you know
they don't actually say anything back to
you
and then they say
you're fine
you're like fine i got right what was
the whole point of that
i don't get it
they're getting paid a lot of money but
um
i think a lot of these people are scared
of me as well you know to take me on as
a
patient because
they know my history
uh
try to get help hot you know it's hard
what
it's hard work you ever you ever gone uh
uh
and spent time with other guys like you
who lived a rough life and were tough
guys as well
and where they found a way to get peace
for them to
share with you how they change their
lives do you have any people like that
you go to or no
no
no i have
a few people that been in jail years and
years they've killed people
and
kill people for the ira and kill people
paid killers yeah um
we're all
we're all the same man we're all the
same we're all
we might talk it you know we might talk
it
and make out
we're all good but really
still all there you know it's still all
there
it's hard work i'm just
telling you the truth not [ __ ] not
want some
uh psychiatrists are told to say
somebody that's not no we're all we're
all [ __ ] man
no no you're fine you're fine
i don't get a feel that you're
being manipulative or you're lying or
you're playing games i feel
i feel you're you like i don't think
you know i i interviewed people that i
feel like they're being faking their act
and i'm like okay
yeah i don't get that feeling at all
from you i get the vibe from you
you know you're you and you're not uh
you probably said some things that you
probably shouldn't have even said well
you said it you're not yeah i know yeah
i know yeah
you know i i
i don't know i i i i don't know if i
would throw in the towel that
a person like you could
uh uh change
you know i know a lot of people that
picked up certain sources that worked on
them
and gradually it's not an overnight
process you know everybody
everybody sins in a different way you
know some people think it is completely
different than yours
but i've seen some crazy people change
yeah yeah i know i you know me i hope
that can happen
it's not happening yet
but there's got to be an effort from you
though i think okay yeah yeah yeah yeah
i don't think it's going to happen
external i don't think i don't if the
personality like like let's just say i
wish you were sitting in my office where
you and i can just have a conversation
a personality like you no one can change
you no one can tell you what to do
nobody yeah
nobody can there's only one person that
can
uh uh uh
change the way you view things only one
person can do that for a guy like you
only
you know and and that starts within you
man that doesn't start with anybody else
because when i want you again i may be
completely wrong
i i see
the
10 year old kid
i see the 16 year old i see the 21 year
old that says if you touch me i'm going
to destroy you
i see the 30 year old i see the son
trying to protect his mom i see the son
trying to defend off his dad
i see all of that combined together i
see all of that when i'm talking to and
it's felt
when i see that and
brother i i uh
i hope you
because you guys still got a lot of
living to do it's not like you're 78 bro
you're 53 you got a lot of living to do
dude you probably got 30 more years to
live
i mean you know it's not you haven't
even lived two thirds of your life yet
which means you know the kids
you know the the grandkids the
potential ways of changing making a
decision to say i'm going to go on a
10-year run to really figure myself out
you got a lot of living to do and if you
do that who knows maybe you'll become an
example to other people that are in a
similar situation like you because you
have true rage in you
you have real rage and pain in you
you do and i don't think that's gonna
leave you in
you know a two week thing or one week
thing or one month thing i think
i think you you you know i i don't know
i'm just saying if you made an effort in
it
it starts with you
don't don't think it's over yet man
you're 53 years old how long oh
yeah you're 53 years old and
it's crazy i have nothing to expect on
how this interview was going to go my
spirit fills you right now
i totally feel this interview right now
like you know i i thought it was just
going to be a story 30 minutes we're off
we're moving and
i'm still on with you i'm going to pray
for you man i'm going to do
from from my end i want to encourage you
to figure out a way to want to do
something uh you know wilder things have
happened where people decided to change
wilder you know remember the man
upstairs rarely uses normal people
he just doesn't the man upstairs doesn't
use normal people i don't know why he
doesn't like normal people to use
as a way because i guess normal people
everybody will say well we always knew
you were going to do well we always know
you can use it he likes to use people
that say oh chet's never going to change
it's chet are you kidding me he's never
going to change he's never going to
change he's never going to change
and somehow someone uses a guy like you
but
um i really enjoy talking to you man i
really enjoy talking to you i felt the
spirit
it's been cool man you're excellent
interview wise
top level top level you
top level thank you
thank you brother
and uh
love to hear some news from you six 12
24 months from now
okay
if you want me again let me know it
definitely will thanks chet appreciate
your time take care everybody
love you all the best god bless
so one question for you we're talking
off camera here do you think a person
like chet can change do you think he can
change at 53 years old august 31st
1968 when he was born he lived the life
that he lived can he change if he can't
change
put thumbs up if you don't think he can
change put thumbs down comment below
saying there's a one percent chance a
chance he can change two percent chance
five percent chance i want to hear your
thoughts at home own opinions and then
if you enjoy this interview there's
other two other movies i want you to
watch one of them is with sean atwood
also from uk who was selling ecstasy in
uh arizona going up against sammy duval
garvano and the other one is killer dave
who did time
got out of jail started his own breadth
company and it took off and eventually
they sold the company i think for a few
hundred million dollars
and uh he ended up eventually changing
his life having said that have a great
day everybody take care bye
[Music]